[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the pledge Joel I
hit the headlines this week after
revealing he'd made a monumental
decision the comedian took to Twitter to
voices outrage over German fashion
company Hugo box allegedly targeting
small businesses who use the word boss
in their names rather than get mad the
funny man decided to get even by legally
changing his name to you guessed it Hugo
Boss which got me thinking about what my
fellow panelists could be called to
highlight things they disagree with femi
you could be will of the people
Nick I'm ordering you to be John Becker
and Rachel it's only right that you
honor the Iron Lady herself
Margaret Thatcher on the program Greg's
hearing the chime of wedding bells
Rachel thinks we need to do more to help
youngsters from ethnic minority
backgrounds I'm saying convicted
domestic abusers should be forced to
take lie-detector tests and Fehmi
is all for girl power but first it's not
the only thing missing was a declaration
of war a stony-faced prime minister
flanked by equally grim face advisors
gravely in toning details of fatality
rates and predicted infection levels yes
this is the nation's response to
coronavirus with the main thrust being
an attempt to contain delay and mitigate
some of the measures that might be taken
include police only investigating
serious crime calling in the army
routine operations being canceled and
no-go zones being created on the one
hand the government is keen to stress
this no need to pan
and everything is under control and yet
on the other it announces deeply
troubling plans such as these meanwhile
as schools close Airlines canceled
flights and collapse stock exchange
around the globe wobble and stores run
out of products such as hand gel and
face masks the media is under attack for
running so-called scare stories surely
it's our job to tell you what's going on
or have we unwittingly added to the
chaos we were as the media unwittingly
helping the chaos but I think the Cavs
is upon us and I don't think the media
now is exaggerating what's around I
think there's something quite serious
going on what is I mean what is worrying
about what is it what is it gonna do to
the economy in all sorts of places in
all sorts of countries I mean I've just
noticed myself in my own life I think
five things I was supposed to be doing
in the next 10 days of big cancelled
which included one was going skiing with
a bunch of people right they didn't want
us all to be in one place at the same
time I'm supposed to be going to a thing
of the University tonight and I found
out there were 20 there and I was the
only one still yeah and I do think there
is there is a degree of panic going on
it's right before I move it on because
you've been in the news business even
longer than I have
how does the media exercise
responsibility in a situation I just get
it wrong and we have now seen panic
buying of toilet rolls I mentioned hand
gel fazer
if you get it wrong you actually
frightened there's always that danger
but I myself could have was quite an
interesting stat which
which I quite like which measures have
you taken to protect yourself from
coronavirus 54% said nothing really now
I think I'm in that 54% improve personal
hygiene 35% avoid crowded public places
14% avoid physical contact with your
personal hygiene or the responsibility
of the media and the markets have the
markets been spooked because of the
global news coverage yes and when you
look at people's companies share prices
you're seeing losses declines in many
areas so yes of course its impact in the
market but it's your central point is
the media fueling this chaos absolutely
and what are ya and what's missing for
me is context so absolutely the media
should be reporting and updating us on
what's going on with Corona
but minute by minute second by second
tallies of who's contracted the virus
and using all manner of scare headlines
and words and you know people bashing
out and there's shortages as you say and
I think it's an Australia toilet paper
so I think two things need to happen I
think that the media need to understand
context because yes this is spreading
but the amount of people that are dying
or getting critically ill because of
this it's a very small number
Femi I would never try and downplay the
seriousness at this aside for my asthma
I'm not in the age group that's most
likely to die from that but I would say
that there was a difference between if
there's a fire in a building if you
shout here's the exit here's the exit
here's the exit you're being
constructive if you shout you're all
gonna die you're all gonna die that's
create what's 9e do you're doing which
one is it doing the media with the fact
that it there's no need to report for
more cases found as but as the headline
why because you know we don't need that
shouldn't I shouldn't you confront a
product you don't know the status be its
own news story the focus should be
government government says do this
you're not you're not helping people do
anything by saying for more cases as a
separate news story yes this story
should include that but okay Rachel do
you not see Ethan
confronted problem if you know its size
ie we've got X number of cases and now
it's X plus white you don't see that I
think a lot of it is to do with tone and
measure and I do just want to show you
this from the Evening Standard just to
look at the kind of reporting that we
have I think this is really
sensationalist and there's no need for
it this kind of terminology war footing
is not necessary look I think that the
media at times like this becomes you
know it's even more important as a
public service you know and it has a
public service requirement to give us
the information that we need to to
manage and reduce the risk of this virus
and one of the things I mean you may
have noticed that I'm not a big fan of
the government but I was impressed with
you know they're starting to have
announcements and advertising and one of
the adverts that they've got coming out
now is a visual about hand-washing and
the frequency with which we need to wash
our hands but they used a visual of a
doorknob that is you know obviously a
surface that you know gets it's a virus
it's a petri dish essentially and they
found that actually using that visual
had more power because the reaction is
discussed than just saying you should
wash your hands you should wash your
hands so I like that they have taken
that consideration and taken advice on
what the most impactful public messaging
is let's just see what the government's
saying before I bring Greg back in
health sector I'm at Hancock we all have
a role to play in stopping this disease
washing hands regularly is the single
most important thing that an individual
can do Public Safety remains our top
priority the government in the NHS are
working 24/7 to fight this virus it's
imperative that everyone follows
clinical advice by contacting NHS
one-one-one and not going to a any if
you develop symptoms it's funny isn't it
great a little while ago we didn't need
experts anymore but the Prime Minister
earlier this week found himself flanked
by two
he needs someone to take the
responsibility he's under attack
apparently we're not right I think it's
very difficult for the media in these
circumstances because I think all of us
I think the media I'm not sure you want
headlines like that but I do think that
it is inevitable that the media will
report it because we want it reported
you know but what I would say you
stopped hugging tourists no I mean I'd
love a hook off a service when I want to
talk to me quite frankly but what I
would say is I'm getting on the fly
after this show I actually am Prince pin
and I've actually started think it's
myself oh god I'm moving an airport
where everyone's been everywhere and do
I need to get them me Greg is right
hasn't it so it has had you are thinking
about it have you changed your life
maybe think a lot more about my phone
because that is also a massive petri
dish apparently but can I just say that
I think that you've raised an
interesting point when you talk about
experts because in a social context
we're being asked in a society where
we've been encouraged to be
individualistic and the government has
undermined our trust we are now being
required to act collectively and on the
basis of the device from my social be
changing life when I was ill isolated
myself so I was what I was worried so I
didn't see my flatmate didn't really go
outside much didn't go to the shops
specifically because I was worried what
if it happens to be that so I have that
done someday but I think the media has
the power to use their headlines to say
hand gels with alcohol and specifically
for example I think it's a really good
thing that we are seeing some empty
shelves that we're where the hand gels
used to be because that why is it good
to see empty shot that just causes panic
I mean it means that people are doing
the one thing that can slow the spread
of this virus
buying hand gels more than most of them
would usually do yeah it's I mean this
is obviously going to run and run this
story I mean I don't know when it ends
and there's all sorts of things I think
that that come into question about
sporting events about theatres about I
don't know why I'm still you keep
cinemas open all these things are gonna
be discussed in them in the weeks as it
moves on